[Music]
hello welcome to this session which we
will be talking about migrating apps to
the cloud and we have a question to you
that's systemic or random and my name is
mamoon Halle I'm a principal cloud
architect with Accenture's Google Center
of Excellence and I'll be joined with my
colleague Greg what Greg buck scamper
who will be talking to us also through
parts of the presentation an important
one as well
so let me spend a minute talk about the
session overview and what we're trying
to accomplish as part of this session
the first part that we are going to talk
about is talk about the business
priorities and challenges with migrating
apps to the cloud and talk about what do
you need to do when you start this
journey of migrating your existing
workloads from either on-prem or
existing cloud provider to Google and
then as part of this process
Greg will walk us through Accenture's
approach for the cloud migration so that
would be the first part that we spend on
on this particular presentation then
I'll take the presentation and talk
specifically about what are the tools
and the best practices that we do as
part of specifically moving these
workloads into Google cloud platform and
then on the third part we will spend
some time talking about some experiences
and sharing some lessons learned from
existing client examples that we have
helped in migrating to the cloud so with
that in mind I'll hand it over to my
colleague here and who will talk who
will walk you through the first part of
the presentation hi good morning my name
is Craig buck scamper I'm one of the
leaders in Accenture journey to cloud
practice and that's really our vendor
agnostic component and so you'll hear me
talk a lot more about process and
methodologies Wallman moon is going to
talk about specific examples and
technologies
so when when our clients start to talk
about moving to cloud there's this this
temptation that we see of clients
looking to say there's all kinds of
technical problems technical debt and
issues that I need to resolve before I
move and when I move to cloud I want to
take advantage full advantage of all of
the capabilities and features that cloud
has to offer and what we see is that can
lead to problems so as an example one of
my clients which is a oil and gas
conglomerate basically they looked at at
their environment and they said we need
to fix all of our Active Directory
issues we need to fix several security
issues and we want to take all of our
applications to pass cloud if I
everything and about two two and a half
years later they basically had nothing
to show for it because they're just
stuck
so in that case greed is not good when
we start to think about planning we have
to look at the the ideal situation in
the situation in the real world and in
an in the ideal situation every
application would be fully standalone
the application stack would be fully
standalone so you have an isolated
application server web server database
server be no interaction and then even
if you peel away the technology the user
communities would be completely separate
there'd be no interaction you had no no
interaction or no conflicts with other
business priorities or other initiatives
but we all know that's not the case so
the reality of the situation is
everything that that we all work on is
very much intertwined right you have
shared database servers you have shared
web farms you you have application teams
that are focused on several priorities
across different applications and you
have to work around those things those
are all things that we have to address
when we're thinking about migration
planning so if we talked about planning
it's really not a binary situation it
really is a spectrum and on the far
left-hand bookend of that you really
have this this concept of just throw
stuff on the truck and move it and and
that's really you know you walk in the
door you grab a few things or you grab
your entire
your your entire portfolio of
applications and servers and you move it
and then you just see what happens and
what we see we actually do have some
clients that try to do this on their own
and what we see it happens is they don't
understand the impacts they experience
major issues during the migration
problems with latency problems with
application and GUI performance and
ultimately their their migration loses
momentum because they lose the support
of the business in the user community on
the other end of the spectrum is that
really the scientific approach and it's
this concept of must understand
everything about the applications and
the servers before you move them and
quite frankly that's just as bad as the
concept of throw everything on the truck
because you can really get stuck in that
analysis paralysis mode and not want to
move until you have perfect information
and so the goal is to find somewhere in
between that suits your organization in
your migration approach one of the next
things that we need to talk about is we
look at migration planning is what are
your business drivers for migrating to
cloud when we first started migrating to
cloud a few years ago really the drivers
were all around these concepts of cost
savings and efficiency get things into
the cloud where we can size for average
utilization we don't have to size for
peak start to make use of that as a
service capability turn things off and
on is needed but now as we look into
cloud there's many more business drivers
and values that you can get out of that
the IT agility and the innovation and
ultimately the business growth and
business agility so we're moving beyond
IT cost to to IT kind of generating
revenue to really cloud driving business
revenue and you have to take that into
account as you do your planning one
example think about it that is a as a
retail client that we had originally had
started to look at cost savings that was
their primary driver but when they got
into it they realized they could start
to take advantage of the the analytics
and machine learning capabilities and
really immediately jumped to getting
this business growth and business
agility so again those those are some of
the factors you need to think about
so you'll hear us talk about the the
different steps and the different data
points that we think you need to collect
when you drain migration planning and
planning really - a lot of people is is
all about what date are we going to
migrate things and and we would argue
that you also need to think about how
are you going to migrate it what
approach are you wanting to take and and
really don't think about that is one
approach for your entire migration think
about that on a per application basis so
there's really a ladder or a curve here
of effort versus benefit and the the the
first adoption or migration method is
really this concept of data center
consolidation or basic capabilities and
this would be moving applications and
servers primarily to to consolidate your
data centers like you'll hear people
moving to cloud just the dr environment
or you may hear them move content to
part of the content delivery network in
order to take off some of the capacity
out of their existing structure the next
step up in that is to just do is lift
and shift migrations so just take your
existing applications with minimal
configuration changes and adjustments
and move them into cloud as is and then
you continue to ramp up and you get into
a little bit of transformation moving to
containers and other technologies like
that or you can do full-blown
transformation and really recode or
refactor your application and take full
advantage of all of you all of the
features and capabilities that cloud has
to has to offer
and like I said one of the things to
think about here is that each
application you can really pick and
choose here if you have an application
that that is verily is not maintained
but is heavily used for certain periods
of the month that really makes sense
from a lift and shift perspective you're
not going to get a lot of benefit out of
refactoring and recoating that
application whereas on the far other end
of the spectrum if you an application
that's driving a lot of business there's
a lot of data coming going it's very
actively developed that's going to make
a lot of sense to think about a
transformation approach and go through
the effort and work to transform that
application and recode it from scratch
potentially ok so as we start to talk
about migration methodology there's
really four challenges that we're trying
to overcome in the migration when we
think about planning the first is
understanding the inventory a lot of
people struggle to understand what are
all of the servers they have in their in
their environment what are all of the
applications that they have in their
environment and then now that really
leads us into the next step which is
sorry the next challenge which is
understanding the dependencies between
those which applications use which
servers which ones are divided out into
your different environments between your
non production in your production
environments and then probably more
importantly for migration and dealing
with some of the additional network
latency that we take on when we move to
cloud is is understanding these
application to application interfaces so
when you move one application what's the
impact going to be to the end-user
experience and is the application still
going to be functional and then on the
backend what's the impact to batch and
those kind of things the third challenge
there is is around optimizing these
repeated efforts if you're moving more
than a few hundred servers there's a
there's a script or a process that
you're going to want to follow and and
that's one of the reasons we talk about
these different migration patterns and
you want to be as efficient in that
process as possible and have the same
script that you're executing over and
over you don't want every migration to
be a snowflake that you have to figure
things out
every time in the last piece that we're
last challenge that we're trying to
address in in planning is really
understanding your resourcing needs
every organization that I know of is
resource constrained and you have to
figure out how to work through that and
how you do that is one of the ways that
you address that is with proper planning
and laying that out laying out your
different move types across your
schedule so that you can predict what
your resource requirements are going to
be one of the reasons that that that we
like our methodology for for planning
these migrations is that we really take
a business driven approach to this so
you'll hear of some migrations being
very server centric they talk in and
they'll just pick up some servers and
move them and and I would argue that's
that's a recipe for disaster that's
gonna cause problems straight away if
you walk in and you begin working with
the business and then go downward
top-down you should see a lot more
success when you're doing your planning
so you start by talking with the
business understanding which business
units want to migrate to make sure they
understand the the value of that and
then naturally you should start to see
business units that are early adopters
or groups even within business units
that are early adopters and some
business units that that want to migrate
later or last from there then you can
start to dive in to their applications
the different environments get to your
your servers and your shared
infrastructure
so this is really the the guts of our
migration planning process and there we
go so it starts on the left-hand side
and that's with understanding your
application inventory and I think it's
probably well understood that you need
to understand what all the applications
are in your environment and you need to
from a technology perspective but you'll
also benefit if you'll start to
understand both also the the business
view of the application when is it used
how's it used how many users components
like security if you do have a little
bit of technical debt that you want to
address understanding that those kind of
components and then same same situation
on the infrastructure side what are our
what are all of those servers in your
environment what operating system are
they running what operating system and
that's particularly - you know if if the
OS is not supported in your future state
environment or you want to use the
opportunity to upgrade but collecting
that kind of information from there then
you're starting to build that mapping or
those linkages between the servers and
the applications and again that's that's
both the application to server which is
one part of it but probably the more
important part of that and the more
difficult part is that application to
application mapping you have to
understand those interfaces so that when
you pick them up and move them you may
have the same thing you move the highly
coupled applications together at the
same time and maintain that in user
usability so then once you map those
infrastructure to applications and
applications to applications then you
need to go through the process of
identifying the move approach and that's
back to determining which of those
applications are going to are going to
get the value of cloud and to what
extent so if you're if you want to
assign the lift I as lift and shift if
you want to do or refactoring or
containerization
need to do all of that thinking or at
least an initial pass during the
migration planning phase then once you
have that mapping and those that move
approach then you take that mapping and
you use that to create your bundles and
bundles or move groups and in our
methodology the the bundle is really the
atomic unit or the smallest unit of
applications and servers that can move
at the same time so you know that as
you're talking about doing a move you
know that bundle that group of servers
and applications all has to move
together if there's a problem it all
moved back together and likewise when
you start to think about waves to us a
wave this is just a date so it's a bun a
wave is a collection of bundles on a
date so then once you have that bundle
or those atomic units of servers and
applications that need to move at the
same time to preserve that end user
experience then you can put them on the
schedule and that schedule really starts
with a a strawman or a framework of what
are your possible move dates and you
typically we we see certain dates fall
out because of month in physical clothes
freeze periods having to do with either
busy times of the year or with holiday
seasons you can also start to see
components of the schedule fall out for
particular business units or particular
application teams because of other
campaigns or other initiatives they have
going on but that's where you place
those bundles on those move dates and
then once you have that you have a
fairly robust schedule at that point
that you can use for resource estimation
in those kinds of things so how we
handle this from an Accenture standpoint
is we actually have have built
instantiated our methodology into a tool
called accelerate for cloud and
accelerate for cloud really is a is a
workflow tool when we looked at the the
tooling environment so there's a lot of
great tools out there to drive these
migrations but they're technical tools
right there they're good tools for
taking the servers and the applications
and getting them up into the cloud it's
not really a lot of good tools
to drive the work behind the migration
and drive all the tasks and so we have
this tool called accelerate for cloud
and it takes us all the way from that
inventory stage where you load in the
inventory and then you start to match
and map it it takes us through an
application questionnaire process where
we ask the we load it up with
information from a CMDB other
spreadsheets and any other data sources
that are possible and then that gets
passed back to the application owners to
validate that information and plug in
other things that we need for the
migration and then from there we can use
that to drive the schedule we use it to
check our bundles so it actually keeps
track of all the mappings that we've
identified and the interfaces between
applications and then we can use that to
validate and make sure that we've
accommodated all those interfaces as
we're putting the bundles together and
then it turns out a number of reports
that allows us to take reports back to
the business and say here's when all of
your applications are migrating go to
individual owners so here's the
different events that you'll have is
that good or bad based on your scenario
in situation and then ultimately it
drives through to the final migration
which is beyond planning but it gets us
down into 15-minute increments during
the actual migration where we can track
the migration of hundreds of servers at
a time can you hear me guys
okay great alright so that was an
important part of the migration that
usually gets forgotten in many small and
medium type of companies who may think
that just because I can take an image or
a server and move it to Google cloud
platform that basically means the
majority of my job is done and reality
is far far far from that and I'm going
to start looking at some of the more
details so Greg gave you the twenty
thousand foot view I'm going now down to
about a thousand foot view you talked
about how we can do some of this in GCP
and what are the implications and things
that you need to be aware of and what
type of some of the adoption patterns
that we see as we talk to our customers
in the field so there are customers who
basically still insist on the fact that
we still want to do it on our own right
and for those who are insisting to do it
on their own basically all the things
that Greg talked about whether that's
the planning figuring out the inventory
the mapping the bundling the scheduling
all of that that basically goes back to
your lab right and if you were to look
at these type of activities here whether
it's assessment planning or the
networking scheduling or their
application or whatever additional
activities that you need to do you need
to take a deep look within your
organization say do I have the
capability the skills the time and
willing to assume the risk if I were to
do that on my own all right so that's
key question you need to think about as
part of your taking that upon yourself
to go and do it from A to Z so that's
just something to point out because
there are still these folks out in the
field that they think they can do it
from A to Z on their own without looking
at it from a holistic type of
perspectives and understanding what are
the implications of the app migration
type of process now if you were to look
at where Google can help I'm sure many
of you have looked at the Google cloud
platform and that's why you're here
trying to look at well what are the
tools the things that would help me as
part of the migration process so if we
were to look at this slide basically to
presents different consumption models
and the things that are the typical
suspects for migrating to the cloud
so when you look at infrastructure as a
service platform as a service in SAS
different companies will be a different
end of the spectrum and some companies
may be at all ends of the spectrum when
it comes to these type of consumption
models so from Google's perspective we
have different type of constructs or
capabilities that would allow you to say
okay well in terms of SAS one of the key
things that we look at is Google Cloud
storage and that's one that we want to
basically just try to get our data on it
start doing some backups that's a
recovery and all of these type of things
past perspective we have lots of
constructs that would help you to get
there as well in terms of the data that
would be required to be migrated with
these type of apps and these are some of
the constructs without its cloud SQL
datastore BigTable bigquery spanner
doesn't matter all of these things are
managed for you and they can be used as
part of the migration and if you're
looking to import or export data from
SAS type of applications you can
leverage the services of data flow that
would allow you to do that from
application perspective you have
different set of options as well so if
you're starting with IAS you have
compute type of capabilities with the
GCE Google compute engine type of
capabilities and you have also the
ability to leverage containers as part
of the process and then you also have
from pass perspective if you don't want
to go and and fiddle with that you can
look at it and say okay well I want to
have the ability to just not worry about
that and leverage things that are
already procured for me and that's where
you leverage Google App Engine and
kubernetes comes somewhere in between
between the two and certainly Apogee
comes into the picture because if you
want to monetize or provide these type
of API interfaces to your applications
that's where Apogee can be part of the
process now what are the migrations that
we see in the field when it comes to GCP
let's start with a simple case the
simplest of cases is Google Cloud
Storage so this is basically somebody is
trying to do backup disaster recovery or
somebody may have a static website that
only contains at this point you know
just watch the HTML and and some
JavaScript
that basically what you can do we can
just migrate all your content into
Google Cloud storage its global it's
replicated content is accessible through
URI you can point the DNS to it the
whole website can be up and running in
minutes so that's something that you can
do if you want to leverage see the ends
you can also look at the ones that
Google has partnered with that makes you
even more faster type of access to it
and caching at the edge of the network
if you are saying well okay that's too
simple for me I have more complex stuff
and that's where you can start looking
at the Google compute engine and we
start looking at well what type of rogue
capabilities and power that Google cloud
platform brings to the table right so
that's where you start looking at
different type of machines that are
available to you whether it's Linux
Windows and and live migration from
Google as part of the process or you can
look at it from I have standard machines
that are available to you out of the box
I need something that's completely
different because I'm special you can
still go and do that create the amount
of CPUs and RAM for you and the storage
that caters to your need rather than
using what Google Offers out of the box
you can have the ability to create
custom images and you can take snapshots
you can make these snapshots available
to other people in different projects
you can also create or deploy a
container image as part of VCE so if you
have built your containers you can
deploy them directly on on VMs from
Google as part of the process and you
have the ability to procure up to 160
cores I just check that in the console
to see what's the maximum because that
number changes so you have up to 160
cores four terabytes of RAM and up to 64
64 terabytes of storage that are
available to you and on top of all of
that you get all the benefits of elastic
type of capabilities are to scale up up
scale down monitoring all of these
things that you get as part of Google
cloud platform on the other end of the
spectrum you might come and say you know
what I don't have the patience to deal
with all of this I want something that's
much easier I just want to go my
developers go give me a Java environment
and they want to start
thing I don't want to fiddle with IAS
and do any of this machine setup or any
of that great so that's where Google App
Engine comes into the picture as part of
the process you have two flavors of
Google App Engine you have the Flex and
standard standard pretty much the same
they're both fully managed type of
environments they're auto-scaling
they're virgin as part of the process
flex gives you more capabilities than
what standard offers standard offers
four languages flex offers you four plus
two and any type of language environment
that you want to add because you can
incorporate this as part of your process
you have the ability to do the the all
of these type of environments are backed
up for you using the datastore SQL or
GCS cloud storage that are available out
of the box the auto scale to zero for
the standard part so basically you can
use it for free if you build it up and
nobody's using it you don't have to pay
for it
for the step for the Flex it scales down
to one so somebody would have to pay for
that if nobody's using it and flex also
gives you additional capabilities like
root access if you want to where you
don't have that as part of standard and
if you're coming and saying well that's
great but I'm a company who is running
significant type of workloads that are
running on my own Prem and they're
taking significant amount of time to be
processed can Google help me with that
of course they can and that's where we
start doing the burst out type of mode
in hyper type of clouds where you can
provide some connectivity between you
and Google there are many options you
can do VPN direct interconnect peering
and you can use the Google cloud power
to get some of this type of workloads
move to the cloud let them run when
you're done they scale down and you
don't pay for additional work that you
don't have to and you don't have to
procure any of the infrastructure or
your on-prem and you don't have to worry
about that ok now I procured all this
infrastructure nobody's using it right
so that's a good option for those type
of companies who may be interested in
that entry point as part of Google cloud
platform so there are many options for
you look at your potential use cases
what you want to do out of that and
select the right path and for you and
look at it from a holistic perspective
as
well and you can look at it from a
tactical perspective if that is the only
thing that you want to look at and
continue with that now as we look at GCP
migration and type of objectives right
there are many stations along the way
where customers look at it and say well
okay my objective from moving to the
cloud is really about you know I want to
have my dev environment or my whole
infrastructure on on Google cloud
because I think it's the right platform
for me from dev testing and production
that would be one option for customers
looking into it other customers may come
and say you know what I all just want to
use it for disaster recovery backup or
others saying you know we heard that you
have great tools and capabilities around
big data and machine learning and that
becomes the primary objective of moving
to the cloud so it it really all depends
on you what you want to do with it but
for for this particular example that I'm
trying to explain here is this is a
company whose primary objective was to
accelerate app delivery and leverage
Google cloud platform to do that and
what type of capabilities that Google
offers to you in this type of realm
right so I talked about the the the GCE
type of components and the fact that we
have Jake EE as well in terms of
kubernetes and the fact that we have
these wonderful clusters that kubernetes
can allow you to spin and scale up and
scale down automatically you have also
the ability for the container builder so
if you want to build containers on GCP
you have the ability to do that and if
you don't want to use docker hub you
have an alternative that is provided to
you through the container registry on
Google cloud platform you have the
ability to leverage App Engine as part
of the process and just announce the
cloud build is also one of these tools
that you can use and look into as part
of the arsenal for building or
accelerating your app delivery on the
cloud you can also have the ability to
import VMs take snapshots images and do
anything you want to with that plus the
availability of all these container
optimized operating systems that are
available to you out of the box from
other customers who may come look at it
and say okay well my destination is
really machine learning in AI because
there are many things that would would
be beneficial to me from my particular
use case and with machine learning in AI
I think you know one of the key things
just to remember and keep in mind is to
sort the hi prom from fax and and the
first thing you need to do whether it's
Google cloud platform any other type of
cloud provider is to understand what are
the real use cases that you're trying to
accomplish right lots of companies right
now are saying we want to do machine
learning yeah I without fully
understanding what does that mean or
without fully selecting the right use
cases and having the right data in order
to get to machine learning so once you
put that aside you have the right data
you have the right use cases you've done
your homework
now what Google cloud platform can help
me as part of that and we have tons of
capabilities but it all starts with the
basics right the basic is basically
getting your data to Google cloud and we
have lots of tools from Google
perspective that allows me to cater to
structured and unstructured type of data
allow me to cater to OLTP or OLAP type
of loads so it really depends on you
what what is the right platform or
construct for you to get the data to
Google cloud once you make these type of
decisions you start looking at what type
of tools that are available to me in
terms of you know I want to use the
Google transfer service or I want to use
gsutil or I want to use any of these
providers that offer the transfer type
of capabilities to me as part of the
process so there are many options to you
and in in previous session I talked
about these options in detail and data
migration to cloud it's the whole
session about that so cannot cover all
of it but but these are part of the key
decisions that you need to make as you
start in this particular journey to
machine learning and then you also have
the ability to do the cloud native
support for Hadoop and that's in the
form of data proc and they just
announced the auto scaling of data
clusters which is a great thing to do
it's in beta right now but it soon will
be in in GA and that would allow you to
automatically scale up scale down in
these type of clusters as you move or
your Hadoop workloads
into Google cloud platform and then we
have the best of breed and
ethics and machine learning tensorflow
is the number one adopted open-source
tool for machine learning it's open
sourced by google right it has been used
in google for a long time it's number
one adopted and we have the bre built
models the perception api's and the auto
ml type of capabilities that are
available to you plus from exploration
and and analysis you have the data
studio data labs and Google Analytics
360 that are part of the mix of the
tools that you need to look into as you
migrate or your destination becomes the
machine learning now a question that
always comes up you know as I move to
the cloud you know lots of companies or
lots of individuals think that your
architecting is is one of those sexy
things that I have to have when I
migrate to the cloud and the answer is
not necessarily true because there are
lots of statistics that show that there
is value in lift and shift so I really
don't have to just react attacked my
applications to the cloud to gain the
benefits of the cloud there are cases
you know where it makes a lot of sense
to go and reaaargh attack the whole
application or portions of the
application so that you could leverage
these type of things but I think you
know one of the key things that you need
to look at am i as an organization
equipped with the right tools and skills
to take on such an endeavor right so
three architecting and and going into
microservices pattern and all of that
stuff and the impact on devops and how
you go from regular monolith type of
systems into suddenly micro services and
and how that impacts the whole
organization is not a trivial one so you
need to be really aware of the
implications of doing that and once you
cross that barrier then yes you're
architecting could be a great thing to
do for the right use cases for the right
situations in this type of example that
I show here this happens to be an
insurance company they had a great
algorithm for underwriting risk however
that algorithm was not taken into
consideration some of the additional
data that's coming from different
sources and they wanted to do something
with it so what to do with that so they
said okay there are certain pieces that
can be refactored or we can start
looking at that data incorporated
and then I can create an API so that
other components of the business could
leverage that new type of functionality
and the architect thing made sense in
this particular example right so it
really depends on your situation now a
question comes up also with the GCP
migration tools from Google what's
out-of-the-box for me if you were to go
to a project in Google and you look at
import VM you will be provided with two
options cloud indoor and velocerator
May 2018 just about two months ago
Google announced that they are acquiring
well-off strata and it would become a
Google company in the coming month or so
there are many sessions on villa strata
but the primary differentiator between
the two cloud indoor is a block level
type of migration so if you have an
application with 10 terabytes 100
terabytes it's a block level migration
that means the whole thing needs to be
migrated and it cannot be operated until
everything gets migrated to the cloud
Velo strata on the other hand allows you
to split the storage from compute and it
migrates the compute to the cloud and it
allows you to execute on the compute
part while it reaches out to the data
that's still in the on-prem type of
situation and then silently it migrates
the data streams it into the cloud and
if something goes wrong you can roll it
back and and stays where it is so it's
pretty neat type of concept as part of
the process on average it's about 10
minutes for migrating images there is an
example on YouTube or they migrate
SugarCRM in about 11 minutes and it's
pretty impressive now I'll just go back
and and and remind you of what Greg
mentioned earlier greed is not good
right because you know you can come and
say ok well if it's that easy let's go
and start migrating no the answer is not
that I'm not trying to say that yes it's
easy and nice but all the things that
Greg have talked about you know the
dependencies the infrastructure all of
that and here are things that you need
to look at as part of your migration you
know it's like as you start where this
where are these VMs going what is my
project structure am i creating one
project multiple projects 10 projects
right
what am i doing about my network and VPC
and IP management is that happening on
its own or somebody doing it for me what
are my DevOps practices how my
developers and engineers are going to do
when these images are suddenly backing
up and how do I get images what where do
I store them right all of these things
are important identity and access
management are you creating the groups
what type of groups what type of roles
you know moving from unprimed to a cloud
type of model are there any things that
you need to do certainly yes and then
you have to look at from security
perspective firewall rules routes etc
what's happening there what ports you
need to open which applications are
talking to which applications and
finally you know who is going to manage
all of that are you going to leveraged a
key driver and what capacity what are
you going to do with the logs what type
of dashboard things intelligence that
you're going to glean out of that I'm
not trying to make it very hard but I'm
just giving you a dose of reality in
terms of you know when you migrate there
are many considerations to consider as
part of the process and all the things
that Greg have talked about that's the
prep work that needs to happen before
you start putting and importing that VM
certainly you need to start with a POC
start in baby steps see how the process
works get some comfort level as part of
the process and then you can look at
much grander type of journey into
migrating process down the road so with
that I'll hand it back over to my
colleague Greg and who will walk you
through example then I will finish the
last two examples so as we look at some
of these client examples we talked about
some of the questions you'd ask and I
think the technical questions are all
pretty apparent to us but we would also
recommend you think about a different
line of questioning around some business
questions and really some some project
management type questions and I think
you'll see how these kind of played out
in the client examples that we're going
to go through but first and foremost to
kind of shape your migration plan and
how you approach planning should talk to
your your the IT and and business on you
know what are the primary reasons for
moving to cloud is it just cost savings
or are you trying to get some of the
additional agility and innovation
and business growth out of that and what
are the expected outcomes again those
those questions are gonna drive some
overall themes and help you understand
if your plan is going to accomplish
those and then from a project management
perspective you really want to think
about you know how fast are you wanting
to move to cloud is that what what does
that mean from a pace so if you if you
want to be done in in six months and you
have 2,000 servers can you actually do
that many servers every month do you
have the capacity to do that or do you
need to look at changing some factor
there what's the budget that'll tell you
you know if your if your plan comes back
and tells you that it's all refactoring
and you know it's gonna take you
thousands of hours per application you
probably don't have the right plan and
then the other the last couple they're
just going to tie into into those so the
first client example here is it's a
leading marketer and distributor of
beverages and this is an organization
that had about a thousand servers it was
a mix of Windows as well as some
proprietary AIX and an eye series that
drove a significant part of the business
process and from a business perspective
they were looking to get away from their
heavy assets and they were looking to
offload everything from their data
center to bottling plants and really
shut down some capability within this
one particular business unit and so how
that played out into their migration
plan is it ended up being basically a
lift and shipped migration of about 500
servers just a regular I as migration
but then they looked at those
proprietary platforms and for the AIX
they did the the business case and they
said that's worth transforming so they
didn't have to pay
AIX and and some of the middleware
service charges going forward and so
they moved about a hundred hundred fifty
servers that way and then they looked at
the iSeries
we looked at a couple of different
things to do with that and ultimately
they said it's too important and we
don't want to invest a lot of money in
this and so they kept that separate and
in a Colo and then as you would expect
and anytime you got any through through
a large transformation about 200
servers that just fell off because of
decommissioning not being used anymore
so why overall it was a success and we
did a significant amount of planning
there were some lessons to be learned
here and this is the initial migration
plan and then the actual migration plan
as it went through evolutions and so you
can see that red dashed line on the left
hand side that was the original
migration plan and then in parallel the
the company was executing an s AP moved
to cloud as well
and ran into some problems there that
sucked up resources that we needed to
use for the non s AP migration and so
that shifted out now the interesting
thing here is why we did have to replan
because we had collected all of the
constraint information and some of the
other business and project management
information when we did the plan we were
able to replan in the course of just a
few days take that back to the business
and application team say does this work
for you they signed off and then we
started to execute again and then you'll
see that we didn't then we had to
replant one more time the other thing
that was going on as they were shifting
their network management to another
provider and that ended up causing some
problems with the network delays and
connections and those kind of things and
again we had to go back to the drawing
board but we were going to do that very
quickly because we already had all the
data collected and we were able to lay
that out again so one of our arguments
here is certainly need to do pretty good
planning but there's you're at a certain
point you lack you won't have control
over some of the parallel initiatives
and you're going to get influenced but
if you're planning data is good if you
collected the right information you can
adjust and pivot to that very quickly
thank you okay so let's walk through our
second example and that's financial and
healthcare services company and that
company basically they wanted to migrate
certain number of applications for a
conference and they wanted to do it fast
so it's right from the get-go do this
quickly right and the assumption is you
know we have done the homework around
which applications we want to migrate
because these are the ones that we
needed and the candidates were provided
to us as part of this process you know
you need to look at it and say okay well
are these the right applications before
you start the migration process because
yes the customer may come and tell you
these are the applications that I want
to migrate one of the key things that
you need to ask what are the
dependencies are these applications
standalone can they function on their
own or there are other dependencies that
you can so if I go and flip the switch
from A to Z and then these applications
once they go to the cloud is that okay
or there are other things that I need to
worry about turns out that one of these
applications was not the right
application to migrate because there
were lots of dependencies that they were
not aware of right so even though that
the customer is the one who recommended
what type of application to migrate they
were not aware of hundred percent of
these type of dependencies and that's
very common it's not every company that
know everything there are lots of people
who know or write this application
without eelain's documentation and doing
something that you may not be aware of
so just pay attention to that as part of
the process so what we did we end up
doing we we designed the right secure
architecture for them in Google cloud
platform we did our due diligence when
it comes to these type of applications
and we selected the right metaphors from
Google's to migrate them and the
applications were migrated and the
project was a success from key lessons
learned perspective is trying to
understand what type of workloads in
general so I'm going to talk in general
here about workload prioritization so
some companies may come and tell you
well what is the criteria for workload
prioritization some companies may
approach it from the fact that you know
from TPS per second transactions per
second so the more TPS per second most
likely that application is more of a
mission-critical right and that becomes
a less likelihood candidate that you
need to migrate first so that's one of
those things that you probably want to
put towards the middle or the bottom of
the list because depending on the
mission criticality if something goes
wrong business may be disrupted so you
may want to start with the ones that are
more simple right the ones that has less
interfaces the ones that may not impact
the business and a significant
analytical workloads are typically one
of these workloads that you can
prioritize to the cloud because what you
can do with that you can learn a lot
from learning from moving these type of
applications to the cloud and and seeing
what type of lessons learned and what
type of skills you have in place so that
you can adjust for the next
mission-critical type of migrations as
part of the process the other lessons
learned is skills I think you know if
you are in the job market and looking
for somebody who knows Google cloud
platform very well you don't find many
of these people in the marketplace right
that is something that a lot of
companies that we know of are struggling
and that is something that you need to
pay attention to as you put your
scheduling plan and and who is the right
partner that you need to work with as
part of the migration process the next
example that I'll talk about the Sailaja
global bank basically that bank operates
in North America and has a global
presence the problem statement was they
wanted to migrate a risk application
that was taking about five hours to
process but significant amount of cost
that has being that's being spent on the
horsepower that is required to go and
figure out all this type of risk and all
of these calculations that needed to
happen so as part of the process we
looked at the application we looked at
the the existing components there were
some we had all the time to do that so
I'll emphasize that because there were
elements of really textured or a
architecting some components of the
application so we had all the time that
we needed to look at it investigate and
figure out okay here are certain
components of refactoring that would be
required looking at the cost that's
being generated or created we looked at
a construct in Google cloud platform
that's called preemptable VMs anybody
heard about preemptable VMs okay very
few preemptable VMs are among those key
wonderful things in Google Cloud where
if your application is not
mission-critical
you basically procure a via
you say I want that to be preemptable
what does that mean Google would
schedule that for you it would run but
if Google needs that capacity for that
VM on a 1-minute notice they'll take it
away they'll Park everything and then
when they're done with that they'll
restart it and it will resume right what
do you get in return for that about 80
percent discount on the cost of the VM
so that's pretty significant so if you
have these workloads that do not need to
be on all the time and you can leverage
preemptable VMs sure all power to you
this app this client saved significant
amount of cost seventy percent of the
cost was saved by reusing preemptable
VMs and we also were able to really tech
some of these applications and use the
micro service pattern as part of the
process but one of the key lessons
learned for the customer here is they
did not have enough people with the
right skills and DevOps and that's where
the partner came in and kind of provided
our own methodology when it comes to how
you could use these type of patterns
within your organization what type of
assessment that would be needed what
type of gaps and what type of
recommendations to fill these gaps were
provided and pretty much it turned out
to be a very successful story at the end
of the day so so the last thing that the
question we asked at the beginning of
the session anybody still thinks that
it's a random job okay good no hands
shown I'll just leave you with this this
is just one comment from a dimensional
research why are application migration
projects are late and over-budget
basically the statistics and the survey
that they have done they found that yes
there is value in moving to the cloud
lots of companies who moved the cloud
were able to achieve the benefit of the
cloud and but the key statement that
they found that initial projects were
more difficult than expected taking a
year or more some of them are failing
seventy-five percent of these projects
that took longer fifty percent of the
participants revealed that they are over
budget so the key things that were
basically uncovered as a reason for that
expertise security concerns resource
shortages and competing priorities were
listed as the primary ones so it goes
back to our story you know don't do over
greed and if you don't have the right
skills leverage your partner as part of
the migration and hopefully it will be a
successful one thank you
[Applause]
[Music]